are you taking a gamble with public
safety Prime Minister three months to
the day since the nation was put on
lockdown
and finally the Prime Minister can go
decisively in the opposite direction and
lift lockdown for most parts of society
from July the fourth people can mix with
friends and family indoors go on holiday
eat out at restaurants go to bars
galleries and cinemas and have a haircut
all when the 2-meter rule is finally
ditched given the significant fall in
the prevalence of the virus we can
change the 2-meter social distancing
rule from the fourth of July where it is
possible to keep two meters apart people
should but where it is not we will
advise people to keep a social distance
of one meter Plus meaning they should
remain one meter apart while taking
mitigations to reduce the risk of
transmission the Prime Minister
deliberately radiating optimism today we
can say that our long national
hibernation is beginning to come to an
end and life is returning to our streets
and to our shops the bustle is starting
to come back and a new but cautious
optimism is palpable the key measures
were supported by the opposition overall
I welcome this statement I believe the
government is trying to do the right
thing and did that we will support them
but if the tone in the Commons was
enthusiastic about the future notice how
in the press conference later the
scientists who have guided the nation
through the last three months were more
cautious the disease is growing across
the world it's coming down in the UK but
it hasn't gone away
this leaves us in some way in the
limited number of options
somehow it burns itself out and
disappears seems extremely unlikely we
are going to be living with this virus
for a very long time
balance and Chris witty you've been
absolutely crystal clear that the risks
from coronavirus haven't gone away and
your tone is noticeably more cautious
than the prime minister how worried are
you that the public reaction to this
overall package might cause an uptick in
transmission I've been absolutely
ruthlessly even-handed in the way that
I've set this out there are there is
progress that we are making important
changes that were able to make to begin
the opening up of the economy but I
think I could not have been clearer that
we must be we must be cautious on an
uptick if people don't take the
mitigation seriously if people hear a
distorted version of what's being said
that says this is all fine now it's gone
away and start behaving in ways that
they normally would have before this
virus happened yes we will get an uptick
for sure personally am I am i
comfortable with it this is a balance of
risk
it's like many things in medicine you
don't go from operation in su up so you
have to it's a balance of risk and I
think that this is a reasonable balance
of risk
it is not risk-free absolutely not
straight there's free nobody thinks it
is and we may at some point say that
particular bit of the decisions that
were taken is too much of a risk in with
the benefit of hindsight and we have to
go back on it but if you journey out of
London you'll find Northern Ireland
Wales and Scotland received the same
scientific advice but reach different
conclusions for now the position here in
Scotland remains the same we are
advising people to maintain two metres
physical distancing we will continue to
take the approach that we have done it
is deliberately cautious because where
our objective is to keep well safe and
will only change if the evidence is
there also changing is the daily press
conference which is now no more waving
goodbye to an institution that guided a
nervous nation through a crisis but a
welcome and brave move from a relatively
new government and they'll only be back
if today's plan hasn't worked
Sam Cote Sky News